Again, we have to find the z scores for each of these. The z score slightly
changes because our sample size is now 50 instead of 30. Now our z score here
becomes about 0.97, which is still outside the critical region. But the z score
for our sample mean is as high as 2.44, approximately. And that's in our
critical region. In this case, based on the results of our sample, we would
reject the null. However, we're pretending that the new population parameter
will be outside the critical region, close to the old population parameter. In
this case, we would reject the null, when the null is actually true. Then we're
committing a Type I error. In this case, it just so happened that we randomly
selected a sample of students who were already really engaged. After all, that
is possible. There's a 2.5% chance that we get a mean with a z score greater
that 1.96.